I got the Jitterbug boom boom I got the
Jitterbug is that Wham I think that's
George Mike is that George Michael I
don't really remember but anyway I'll
soon be able to remember because George
Michael might go on tour again seven
years after he died
how is he going to do that you ask well
through Holograms
already the band members in Wham
uh Shirley Kemp George Michael's best
friend in Wham suggested the idea and
this was backed by fellow backing singer
Helen Pepsi demok croquette
who is also up for this
there's precedent for it it's not just a
fantasy Abba did this last year you know
Abba like Mamma Mia here I go again Abba
did their first gig in 42 years how'd
they do it in hologram form at London's
Queen Elizabeth Olympic Park they
referred to this group of performers not
just as Abba but as avatars
get it
avatars
and it showed them as they looked in
1979.
on the one hand I don't want to seem
like a total Doom and Gloom Luddite even
though I am kind of a Luddite and I
don't love most forms of technology but
I don't want to seem like all
technological advancement is bad it's
not in a way this is just the latest
advance of a multimedia landscape okay
we used to be able to watch movies in
the theater then we could watch movies
at home then we could watch little
glittery images on our pocket and now we
can see them in 3D in space and they can
perform okay fine but I think there's
something deeper here
I think this speaks to our culture's
unwillingness to accept death
everybody's got to be eternally Young
nobody can ever die Kanye West had a
hologram of Kim Kardashian's father
recite some words that I guess he had
written for it at Kim Kardashian's
birthday party and I thought man this is
really I would not like this as a
birthday present
because you miss your loved ones who
have gone and so it can be really sweet
in a way it can be really nice and
satisfying to see them again but it's
not
real they're dead they're really dead
we're all gonna die Peter Cushing is
dead he I know he's in the the fairly
recent Star Wars but he's dead and it's
weird to just not let people die Steve
Jobs gave that famous speech at the
Stanford commencement it was one of the
best commencement addresses in recent
memory on how
death is one of the most important parts
of life
remembering that I'll be dead soon is
the most important tool I've ever
encountered to help me make the big
choices in life
because almost everything all external
expectations all Pride all fear of
embarrassment or failure these things
just fall away in the face of death
leaving only what is truly important
remembering that you are going to die is
the best way I know to avoid the Trap of
thinking you have something to lose you
are already naked there is no reason not
to follow your heart your time is
limited so don't waste it living someone
else's life
don't be trapped by Dogma which is
living with the results of other
people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drowned out your own inner voice and
most important have the courage to
follow your heart and intuition they
somehow already know what you truly want
to become everything else is secondary
the whole speech is quite good
that first part is the key
death is one of the most important
things I've ever seen in life death
gives meaning to your life death gives
narrative structure to your life
it's got a beginning a middle and an end
right now go to
samaritanministries.org Knowles how are
you paying for your health care how's it
working out for you if it's working
perfectly great if not listen closely
because I've got a solution for you a
Biblical solution called Samaritan
Ministries Samaritan Ministries is a
community of Christians paying one
another's medical bills it's affordable
health care sharing and because it's not
Insurance there are no restrictive
networks here's how it works when a
medical need arises you choose the
health care provider that is right for
you and have a say in the treatment you
receive send your medical bills to
Samaritan Ministries they will notify
fellow members to pray for you and send
money directly to you to help you pay
those bills it could be more affordable
than what you're paying right now and if
it's the right fit you can join anytime
even today check it out at
samaritanministries.org Knowles k o w l
e s I know a lot of people are
dissatisfied with the way our health
care System currently works in the
United States well here is a great
alternative to check out that would be
samaritanministries.org slash Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s
death concentrates the mind there's a
famous saying of Dr Johnson
which I I sometimes quote as proving the
medicinal benefits of capital punishment
which is depend upon it sir when a man
knows he's to be hanged in a fortnight
it concentrates his mind wonderfully
well we're all going to be hanged in a
fortnight in a certain way we're all
going to die no one here Gets Out Alive
even if we have Holograms all around us
even if we keep putting Peter Cushing in
movies we are going to die
and the sooner you recognize that the
better because it's going to wake you up
and get your life in order and for
certain questions on you is this it do
we just take a dirt nap and turn to worm
food or is there more to life is there
more in Heaven and Earth than is dreamed
of in our philosophies is am I just my
body am I also my soul well if I am a
soul what is the me what happens to the
soul after death is there more to the
story even for my body
is there a moral order
could I be punished is there Justice
eternally is there such a thing as
eternity what you have to face these
questions when you look at death which
is why our liberal culture which is why
the principalities and powers of this
world and spiritual wickedness in high
places
wants to distract you from death
and has broadly succeeded in Modern Life
we don't see death a lot
when our grandparents are going to die
they go away to Little Homes and we
don't see they go to hospice places we
don't have to see it in our own homes
we do when when people die now you don't
really go to funerals as much you go to
celebrations of life
so called you don't even usually see a
body or even a casket you just it's
later it's no big deal we just kind of
chew it away
and because modernity has succeeded at
greatly extending people's lives
then they usually they just die when
they're very very old they're kind of
out of the way we don't pay attention to
that anymore that's
some ways more pleasant because death is
deeply unpleasant
when Christ himself when his when his
friend Lazarus died he Weeps
shortest verse in the Bible Jesus wept
but
then we lose focus and then we forget
what we're doing before I go I I meant
to get to this a few days ago Tony
Bennett died Tony Bennett uh I love Tony
Bennett was listening to Tony Bennett
the other day while I was making fresh
pasta with my son uh he's great he's
wonderful and the reason why it's so
particularly sad that he died I mean
look he lived a good long life 96 years
old cut down in his prime flipped his
Corvette that's it no that's not how he
went he died after a battle with
Alzheimer's disease and even for five
years after his Alzheimer's diagnosis he
continued to tour the guy was just a
total inspiration the reason it's so sad
that he died is he's the last of his
kind
because he's he's younger than the other
guys you think of Sinatra Dean Martin
Sinatra was born in 1915. Dean Martin
was born in 1917. uh Tony Bennett was
born in 1926 so Sinatra for Bennett's
whole career referred to Tony Bennett as
the kid
up until satra's Dying Day called him
the kid even though Bennett was a pretty
old man at that point
and so that generation of music that
crooning that that dignified sensibility
that was at least dignified in public if
not always in private comportment for
for some of people of that generation
that's gone now
now public comportment for our popular
musicians is absolutely disgusting and
the lyrics are disgusting and the way
they jiggle around us and but Tony
Bennett and Sinatra and all those guys
they had class they'd put on a jacket
and Italian they would sing and they
would sing in a way that was really
delightful in edifying so anyway R.I.P
to Tony Bennett and a reminder by the
way I know some people say they don't
they don't pray for the dead because it
contradicts their religious views if
you've ever said R.I.P you have prayed
for the dead because your rip means may
he Rest In Peace requiest So Requiem
Scott and Pache Tony Bennett great guy
provided us a lot of great stuff over
the years and I don't look forward to
seeing this hologram but I do look
forward to playing more of his music boy
what a great clip that was now make sure
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time